die hansestadt rostock hat sich ein
attraktives neubaugebiet direkt am
wasser geleistet im ehemaligen
hafenbereich sind schick appartements
entstanden
die straßen sind aber alles andere als
schick nein die sind desolat die
fahrbahn und bürgersteige sind komplett
abgesagt bis zu 60 zentimeter bordsteine
brechen weg der boden des parkhauses
sieht aus wie eine buckelpiste
das ist ja wahnsinn er also kataster
muss die stadt sich jetzt gedanken
machen ich bin selbst ingenieur und das
gehört eigentlich dazu dass man eine
gründliche analyse von den dingen macht
wo man baut man muss gucken wo man dann
hier genau hochkommt die absackung sind
ja auch inzwischen schon teilweise sehr
hoch und das ist schon auf jeden fall
abenteuerlich dass es ein abenteuer
werden würde auf dem schlammigen
untergrund zu bauen war der stadt
rostock von anfang an bekannt
deshalb werden die häuser auf solche
eisenträger gebaut die im erdreich
versenkt werden ein teures verfahren
aber alternativlos auf solch ein festes
fundament hat die stadt jedoch bei den
straßen und wegen verzichtet deshalb
sieht es hier so aus überall
stolperfallen und warnschilder die
reparatur wird nun unfassbar teuer alle
straßen samt rohren und leitungen müssen
saniert werden die kosten sagenhafte 15
millionen euro
im rostocker rathaus versucht man das
bau desaster zu erklären
es ist kein offensichtlicher fehler ist
es ein durchaus übliches verfahren nur
an der stelle hat nicht geklappt
man ist nicht auf nummer sicher gegangen
die folgen sind dramatisch und die
löcher im boden mittlerweile
unübersehbar die straßen denn mehr
abgesagt als es zu erwarten war dass wir
jetzt nacharbeiten müssen zeigt dass wir
damals an der falschen stelle gespart
haben die stolper strecken nerven die
anwohner und werden zum teuren ärgernis
für alle rostocker dass das bezahlen
muss also dass das geht mir auch ein
bisschen auf den keks ein parcours ich
meine für den lippen der finne
toll wenn es ein bisschen wackelt für
die mutter ist es natürlich ein bisschen
anstrengen
ich weiß nicht ob wir keine ingenieure
haben oder alles schien nur auf das geld
die stadt hat jetzt einen sanierungsplan
in auftrag gegeben um die straßen zu
retten das neubauviertel wird also schon
bald wieder zur großbaustelle werden